[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara häufig 7 haben ihnen allen kurze
unterbrechung der sportberichterstattung
aus münchen wir bringen sie in den
kommenden zehn minuten auf den neuesten
nachrichten stand unter anderem mit
diesen themen
tonnenweise tote fische die rätselhafte
giftwelle in der oder bedroht jetzt auch
die ostsee
wie viel ärger droht donald trump das
fbi beschlagnahmte im wohnsitz des
ex-präsidenten streng geheime dokumente
und ein leben in angst ein jahr nach dem
abzug der bundeswehr aus afghanistan
hoffen tausende ehemalige ortskräfte
noch auf eine ausreise nach deutschland
am oderufer in brandenburg haben heute
hunderte helfer
fischkadaver eingesammelt
bundesumweltministerin lemke ist im
moment vor ort sie waren vor einer
drohenden umweltkatastrophe
die ursache ist immer noch nicht ganz
klar
vermutlich ende juli kamen giftstoffe
oder chemieabfälle in polen in die oder
mitte der woche dann auch im
brandenburgischen frankfurt ein massives
fischsterben und jetzt rechnen die
behörden damit dass die schadstoffe auch
das stettiner haff und die ostsee
erreichen katrin lindner und jan meyer
berichten
auch dieser welt hat die umwelt
katastrophe nicht überlebt an 17 stellen
entlang der oder haben heute über 300
freiwillige allein im landkreis
märkisch-oderland fischer eingesammelt
rund 20 tonnen
große fischer kleine fische schnecken ja
ganz ganz trauriges bild weil die fische
hat wirklich schon entweder klein oder
groß sind und wirklich schon stark
verwest polens regierung und behörden
stehen unter druck weil sie zu spät
reagiert haben der polnische
ministerpräsident in dies am
freitagabend den chef der wasserbehörde
und den leiter der umweltbehörde
umgerechnet 210.000 euro belohnung hat
die polnische polizei für hinweise
ausgelobt
wir wollen die schuldigen finden und die
verursache dieses umwelt verbrechens
bestrafen mit dem wir es hier
höchstwahrscheinlich zu tun haben
die freiwilligen helfer an der ote
wissen noch nicht ob die toten tiere
sondermüll sind die ursache ist nach wie
vor ungeklärt erhöhte satz wehrte wurden
gemessen weitere untersuchungen laufen
auch hohe temperaturen und niedrige
wasserstände können ursache sein
mecklenburg vorpommern rechnet damit
dass der giftcocktail morgen das
stettiner haff erreichen könnte
ja wer darum gebeten dass das angeln das
eingestellt wird und dass die fische
gefangen werden wir sind in der hoch
tourismussaison dass diese fische nicht
genutzt werden die britische reis auch
gebeten worden die netze einzuholen und
auch das baden im hafen soll möglichst
unterlassen werden welche substanzen sie
getötet haben kommende woche rechnet das
landeslabor berlin-brandenburg mit
ergebnissen
fragen wir jan meyer in frankfurt an der
oder wir gehen die menschen mit dieser
situation um
das ausmaß des fischsterbens ist
erschreckend der anblick des tod
wirkenden flusses trost muss der gestank
von totem fisch legt sich fast über die
gesamte ufer region und die menschen
hier können nur aktiv eines tun tote
fische aus dem ufer aus dem fluss bergen
das tun sie auch gesammelt werden sie in
der
tierkörperbeseitigungsanlage in seelow
dort werden die kadaver normalerweise
verarbeitet zu tiermehl und tierfutter
doch dieses mal handelt es sich ja wohl
ungiftigen sondermüll besonders quälend
ist aber dass die ursache einfach nicht
gefunden wird das landeslabor wollte
gestern ergebnisse bekanntgeben tut dies
nun wahrscheinlich erst am montag
deswegen können die menschen auch morgen
wiederum nur eines tun an die oder gehen
ausschau halten nach toten fischen und
die dann so schnell wie möglich aus dem
fluss holen danke nach frankfurt ihren
meyers der schriftsteller salman rushdie
wird nach dem messerangriff im
us-bundesstaat new york künstlich
beatmet sein zustand ist ernst ein stich
habe die leber getroffen sagt sein agent
der 75-jährige werde möglicherweise ein
auge verlieren nach polizeiangaben hatte
ein 24 jähriger bei einer lesung
mehrfach auf rushdie eingestochen warum
ist bisher unklar
die hausdurchsuchung bei donald trump in
florida anfang der woche hatte große
wellen geschlagen jetzt gab das
justizministerium bekannt das fbi habe
am wohnsitz des früheren us-präsidenten
streng geheime dokumente beschlagnahmt
auch zu atomwaffen immer tee wissen hat
mir
die ermittler fanden in marl lago genau
das was sie suchten staatsgeheimnisse
der richterliche beschluss basiert unter
anderem auf amerikas spionage gesetz das
schon die mitnahme und falsche
aufbewahrung von geheimdokumenten unter
strafe stellt auf der liste des
beschlagnahmten materials auch
unterlagen über frankreichs präsident
makro insgesamt elf ordner mit
geheimhaltungsstufen drei dokumenten
setzte streng geheim ein weiterer so
geheim dass nur ganz wenige personen den
inhalt kennen dürfen warum trump sie mit
nochmals das weiße haus verließ ist
unklar respekt vor geheimhaltungs regeln
hatte er nie sagt sein ehemaliger
sicherheitsberater der ging sorglos mit
dokumenten und wusste die wichtigkeit
der regel nicht zu schätzen
schwamb behauptet nun dass ein präsident
formlos die geheimhaltung aufheben kann
genau das so sein statement habe er
damals auch getan doch dokumente aus dem
pentagon über atomwaffen unterliegen der
obersten geheimhaltungsstufe top secret
sc ii kein präsident kann sie aufheben
tier ssc ii stand auf unterlagen aus
marl lage
in ähnlichen fällen so der ehemalige
spionageabwehr chef im justizministerium
wurden personen deshalb angeklagt es ist
schockierend so etwas im
durchsuchungsbeschluss gegen einen
ehemaligen us präsidenten zu sehen
die ermittler nach auswertung ihrer
funde nun entscheiden ob sie gegen
donald trump anklage erheben
seit einem jahr sind in afghanistan die
radikal islamischen taliban wieder an
der macht trotz aller versprechen
schränken sind die rechte von frauen
massiv ein dagegen gingen heute in kabul
rund 40 afghaninnen auf die straße bis
taliban-kämpfer ihren protest gewaltsam
beendeten
nach wie vor warten in afghanistan
ehemalige ortskräfte der bundeswehr
darauf dass sie wie versprochen nach
deutschland ausreisen können eine
konferenz in berlin versucht zu helfen
ines trams
ein paar dokumente hat massa auf seiner
flucht aus afghanistan mitnehmen können
aus seiner zeit als dolmetscher für die
bundeswehr ein verräter in den augen der
taliban er zeigt uns eines ihrer
drohschreiben an ihn er sorgt sich um
die ortskräfte die zurückbleiben mussten
wir da angst zum beispiel kann man nicht
in der öffentlichkeit zu rücken
manche gehen also dass nicht jemand
kommt und sagt
ja wir kennen dich dass du da und da
gearbeitet hast und dann darf einmal die
taliban kommen und
verhärtet die münchen mit anderen
ehemaligen kollegen beim ortskräfte
kongress in berlin teilt diese sorge sie
alle wollen wissen wann dürfen familien
und kollegen nachkommen doch der prozess
stockt auch weil es in der ampel
koalition knirscht
das betrifft jetzt nicht nur die
ortskräfte sondern auch das
aufnahmeprogramm für afghaninnen und
afghanen
das leider immer noch nicht umgesetzt
ist obwohl wir jetzt schon ein jahr bald
regieren aber
das versprechen bleibt der
bundeswehrverband fordert eine klarere
regelung wer erzählt all sorts kraft als
arbeitgeber dürfe man nicht vertrauen
verspielen denn ohne sie kein einsatz
ohne die ortskräfte wird der einsatz in
afghanistan für die bundeswehr nicht
hubschrauber gewesen die ortskräfte
waren für uns sensoren multiplikatoren
übersetzer unterstützer massud zumindest
verlässt den kongress mit hoffnung dass
deutschland ein jahr nach dem abzug
wieder auf die schaut die in afghanistan
bleiben mussten
ein amoklauf erschüttert das kleine
adrialand montenegro mindestens elf
menschen starben dabei mit einem
jagdgewehr erschoss ein 34 jähriger in
der kleinstadt linie eine frau und ihre
acht und zehn jahre alten kinder die
familie hatte in einer der wohnungen des
täters gelebt anschließend feuerte er
offenbar wahllos auf menschen auf der
straße schließlich erschoss ihn ein
passant
berlin hat der opfer an der
innerdeutschen grenze gedacht am 61
jahrestag des mauerbaus bei der
zentralen gedenkfeier an der bernauer
straße legte die regierende
bürgermeisterin gefeiert ein kranz
nieder sie erinnerte auch an den 18
jährigen peter fechter einer von
mindestens 140 menschen die allein an
der berliner mauer durch das
ddr-grenzregime starben
noch das wetter das bringt morgen viel
sonne nur zwischen nordsee und
erzgebirge dichtere wolken und einzelne
schauer details hat gleich christa
thoben 20 vor elf begrüßt sie marietta
slomka im heute journal ich wünsche
ihnen noch einen schönen abend und viel
spaß weiter beim sport live aus münchen
das machen wenn sie mögen
[Musik]
haben am montag kündigen sich örtlich
schauer und gewitter an die abkühlung
ist allerdings nur bedingt wie uns hier
der temperatur trend von berlin mit
immer noch über 30 grad zeigt erst am
donnerstag gibt es eine deutliche
abkühlung und auch die chance auf etwas
mehr regen so dass die waldbrandgefahr
mal wieder abnimmt heute nacht lassen
die schauer im osten rasch nach hier ist
es dann wolkig sonst klar bei teils
kühlen 9 grad an den alpen gegenüber
tropischen 20 grad an der ostfriesischen
küste morgen gibt es viel sonne mal ein
paar wolken wie im südwesten von der
nordsee bis zum erzgebirge sind die auch
etwas dichter und können abends dann
einzelne schauer und gewitter im gepäck
haben dazu weht ein lebhafter ostwind
und es ist heiß bei 28 bis 34 grad nur
auf rügen gibt es um 26 grad am montag
da kommt dann der wetterumschwung dessen
regenmengen allerdings nicht ausreichen
um die trockenheit zu lindern am
dienstag ist wieder sonnig und trocken
heiß bis zum mittwoch ab dann von westen
her steigt die chance auf mehr regen das
war es von uns